Alice: 哎我们家的油呢
Alice: Hey, where's our oil?
Tasha: 呃玉米油行吗
Tasha: Uh, is corn oil okay?
Jake:现在在做什么
Jake: What are you doing now?
Lucia: 呃小蛋糕
Lucia: Uh, making little cakes.
Jake:蛋糕嗯
Jake: Cakes, huh?
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 我也不下去了
Lucia: I'm not going down anymore.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 开饭了
Jake: Time to eat.
Tasha: 哦烤上啦
Tasha: Oh, it's grilled!
Jake: 呜呜呜呜呜呜
Jake: Woo woo woo woo woo!
Jake: 虽然完全不知道怎么做的
Jake: Even though I have no idea how it was made...
Jake: 但是一定很好吃
Jake: ...it must be delicious.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Tasha: 这个也快好了好像
Tasha: This one seems almost done too.
Lucia: 你错过了这个非常精彩的打蛋环节真的很神奇
Lucia: You missed the amazing egg-cracking part, it was really magical.
Jake: 哦怎么个
Jake: Oh, how so?
Jake: 发起来的是吧
Jake: Did it rise?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 虽然没打成那种泡沫状的
Lucia: Though it didn't turn into that foam-like state.
Jake: 哦可以没事你们踩到了数据
Jake: Oh, it's okay, did you guys record the data?
Tasha: 哈哈哈他晚上回去看数据
Tasha: Hahaha, he'll check the data when he gets home tonight.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈  对呵
Jake: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake: 让世界研究员们都看到
Jake: Let the world researchers see.
Jake: 这个鸡蛋哎
Jake: This egg, hey...
Jake: 怎么打碎了呀
Jake: ...how did it break?
Jake: 打碎的瞬间
Jake: The moment it broke...
Alice: 为什么这个汤变成这个样子
Alice: Why did this soup turn out like this?
Jake: 这是咋回事
Jake: What's going on?
Alice: 好暗啊
Alice: It's so dark.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:这是怎么发生的什么
Jake: How did this happen, what?
Tasha: 这是鸡蛋
Tasha: This is an egg.
Tasha: 不小心它自己跑到桌上了
Tasha: It accidentally ended up on the table by itself.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 就是鸡蛋变成了鸡
Jake: The egg turned into a chicken...
Jake: 然后爬到了桌上
Jake: ...then climbed onto the table...
Jake: 又变成了鸡蛋
Jake: ...and turned back into an egg.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 这是被我们惩罚的鸡蛋
Tasha: This is an egg we punished.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling about this.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:我有不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling about this.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Alice: 感觉要翻车了
Alice: Feels like we're gonna fail.
Lucia: 这个是是
Lucia: This is...
Alice:你洗的叶子
Alice: You washed the leaves.
Jake: 好我看一下
Jake: Alright, let me take a look.
Jake: 我来研究研究
Jake: Let me study this.
Jake: 它感觉要转出来了离奇
Jake: It feels like it's about to spin out, strange.
Lucia: 我刚才拿了一下我看他底下好像没有网一样的感觉我就我就不敢不敢一直把他拿起来了
Lucia: I just held it for a bit and it felt like there was no mesh underneath, so I didn't dare to keep holding it.
Alice: 大白菜还是太冒险了
Alice: Napa cabbage is still too risky.
Jake: 我也我也
Jake: Me too, me too.
Jake: 整不明白
Jake: I can't figure it out.
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 感觉他底下没有网
Lucia: Feels like there's no mesh at the bottom.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 那这哎
Jake: So this, hey...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake: 那这个怎么办呀呵呵
Jake: So what do we do about this, haha.
Jake: 这也只能打开吧
Jake: We can only open it, right?
Lucia: 对他如果透出好像下不去哦有网sorry
Lucia: Yeah, if it shows through, it seems like it can't go down, oh there's mesh, sorry.
Lucia: 是一种试错觉的效果
Lucia: It's like an optical illusion effect.
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Tasha: 我去开会了
Tasha: I'm going to a meeting.
Tasha: 5分钟时间
Tasha: 5 minutes.
Jake:一会见
Jake: See you later.
Tasha: 呃现在2335吧
Tasha: Uh, it's 23:35 now.
Alice: 不知道为什么
Alice: I don't know why...
Alice: 这个颜色变成这个样子了
Alice: This color turned out like this.
Alice: 感觉要翻车了
Alice: Feels like we're gonna fail.
Alice: 怎么办好害怕
Alice: What do we do, so scared.
Jake: 别怕别怕
Jake: Don't be scared, don't be scared.
Jake: 好吃
Jake: It's tasty.
Alice: 好吃吗
Alice: Is it tasty?
Jake: 好吃，对一定好吃
Jake: Tasty, yes, definitely tasty.
Alice: 我我我已经开始害怕了
Alice: I'm, I'm, I'm already starting to get scared.
Alice: 有一种不太妙的预感
Alice: I have a bad feeling.
Tasha: 充电宝
Tasha: Power bank.
Tasha: 充电宝有充电的吗
Tasha: Is there a charged power bank?
Jake:嗯哼 有的
Jake: Uh-huh, there is.
Jake: 应该有吧
Jake: There should be.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh man
Jake: 给你个46怎么样
Jake: How about a 46 for you?
Jake: 可是我没有充电线呀
Jake: But I don't have a charging cable
Jake: 你是什么
Jake: What do you have?
Tasha: 我想要自带线的好苹果
Tasha: I want a good Apple with a built-in cable
Jake:哎哎哎
Jake: Hey, hey, hey
Tasha: 喂 喂听不见听不见你说话
Tasha: Hello, hello, I can't hear you, I can't hear you talking
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you
Alice: 白菜帮不要
Alice: Don't need the cabbage core
Tasha: 听不见
Tasha: Can't hear
Lucia: 那个碗伸那去了
Lucia: Where did that bowl go?
Tasha: 是烧菜的吗
Tasha: Is it for cooking?
Alice: 啊可能是
Alice: Ah, maybe
Alice: 呃没事再重拉一个
Alice: Uh, no worries, just make a new one
Jake: 对再拉
Jake: Yeah, make a new one
Jake: 额刚刚我刚刚我头在下面一直一刀下去
Jake: Uh, just now, just now, my head was down, and a knife came down
Jake: 哈哈哈就感觉断头的感觉
Jake: Hahaha, felt like a beheading
Jake: 有一种哎呀Lucia你好像你好像
Jake: It was like, oh Lucia, you seemed like, you seemed like
Lucia: 需要一个碗
Lucia: Need a bowl
Jake: 这个灯不亮了
Jake: This light is not on
Jake: 可能是满了
Jake: Maybe it's full
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 你要不看一下
Jake: Can you check?
Lucia: 稍等
Lucia: Just a moment
Lucia: 不太可能呗刚刚我一直想的是
Lucia: It's unlikely, I was thinking just now
Jake:可能是
Jake: Maybe
Jake: 看一下吧
Jake: Check it out
Jake: 满了或者他自己
Jake: It's full or maybe it
Tasha: 还是听不见哦
Tasha: Still can't hear
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see
Lucia: 连着呢
Lucia: It's connected
Jake: 没关系就在你那
Jake: No worries, it's just with you
Lucia: 但是我点开她点成了这样
Lucia: But when I clicked, it turned like this
Tasha: 可不可能是我的问题
Tasha: Could it be my problem?
Jake:weikelaike哦
Jake: Maybe, maybe
Tasha: 应该不是吧
Tasha: Probably not
Jake: 没事吧就是在新开一个，然后校个准
Jake: It's okay, just open a new one and recalibrate
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey
Jake: 我看一下你的这个灯还亮不亮
Jake: Let me check if your light is still on
Jake: 关机了呢
Jake: It's turned off
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 关机了不知道怎么样关机了
Jake: It's turned off, don't know how it turned off
Lucia: 嗯可是他冲了很长时间的电
Lucia: Hmm, but it has been charging for a long time
Lucia: 我猜他应该是有变的
Lucia: I guess it should have power
Lucia: 不会没电了吧
Lucia: Could it be out of battery?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Let me check again
Alice: 盐在哪里
Alice: Where's the salt?
Lucia: 他现在还没连上了吗
Lucia: Is it still not connected?
Jake:还在loading
Jake: It's still loading
Jake: OK
Jake: 哦没电了哎
Jake: Oh, it's out of battery
Jake: 为什么呀是没充上吗
Jake: Why? Did it not charge?
Lucia: 啊不应该啊
Lucia: Ah, it shouldn't be
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia: 对他
Lucia: Yeah, it
Jake: 没事哦感觉没没插进去
Jake: It's okay, it seems like it wasn't plugged in properly
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Jake: 可能也不是
Jake: Maybe not
Lucia: 他好像只能插到这
Lucia: It seems it can only be plugged in this far
Jake: 啊只能插到这
Jake: Ah, only this far?
Jake: 那就不是没插进去
Jake: Then it wasn't unplugged
Lucia: 他这里有有一段不过可能中间他他断了
Lucia: There is a section here but maybe it got disconnected in the middle
Jake: 没事没事没事继续
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, keep going
Lucia: 应该没电断了那那现在要继续把他吸
Lucia: It should be out of battery, so now we need to keep it plugged in
Jake: 哎是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake: 就要插着电了
Jake: Just need to keep it plugged in
Jake: 刚好现在有兜了
Jake: Now we have pockets
Lucia: 对对对我刚好现在有兜了
Lucia: Yes, yes, now I have pockets
Jake: 好
Jake: Good
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 那我要怎么把他重新命名一下吗
Lucia: So, how do I rename it?
Lucia: 命名现在的时间
Lucia: Rename it to the current time
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay
Jake: 这样的话其实是别人没电就你还有电还能行
Jake: This way, when others run out of battery, you still have power and can keep going
Jake: 因为大家可能很快
Jake: Because everyone might quickly
Jake: 不是没有点是没有storage
Jake: 就你还有很多storage
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 就是所有状况都可以解释
Jake: Everything can be explained.
Jake: 最后写下来的时候都可以解释
Jake: When it's all written down, it can all be explained.
Lucia: Out, not ready他又变成可难听了
Lucia: Out, not ready, he said it again, it sounds so bad.
Jake: 现在好了
Jake: Now it's okay.
Jake: 嗯现在是2024
Jake: Hmm, now it's 2024.
Lucia: 现在是
Lucia: Now it's...
Jake: 4162028
Jake: 4162028.
Lucia: 2028
Lucia: 2028.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我在弄一下
Lucia: I'll fix it a bit.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧那就过一会吧
Jake: Okay, let's wait for a while.
Lucia: 那让他先冲一会好吧
Lucia: Let it charge for a while, okay?
Jake: 对对对充一会也放这
Jake: Yeah, let it charge for a while, just leave it there.
Jake: 放一会
Jake: Leave it for a bit.
Tasha: 喂可以，你可以说话了刚我听见了
Tasha: Hey, okay, you can talk now, I heard it just now.
Lucia: 冲一会也行
Lucia: It's fine to charge for a while too.
Jake: 放到里面充吧
Jake: Charge it inside.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 那样会更快一点还是你可以顺便导数据哈哈哈
Lucia: It might be faster that way, or you can transfer the data meanwhile, haha.
Lucia: 导数据
Lucia: Transfer data.
Jake: 可以这样
Jake: We can do that.
Jake: 那你就是担当，接下来一晚上的担当
Jake: Then you're in charge, you're in charge for the whole night.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake:哈 哈哈哈哈直接导数据好了
Jake: Haha, just transfer the data directly.
Jake:L4
Jake: L4.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没有我再看一眼你再发那个
Lucia: No, let me take another look and then you send that.
Tasha: 我我什么都没发在瞎画
Tasha: I, I didn't send anything, just doodling.
Lucia: 这是个什么表情包吗
Lucia: Is this an emoji?
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 啊没有没有我是说你在设计一个表情包
Lucia: No, no, I mean are you designing an emoji?
Tasha: 好我也希望
Tasha: Well, I hope so.
Tasha: 哇网好差啊
Tasha: Wow, the internet is so bad.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Lucia: 是有一点刚才特奶糖停了很长时间
Lucia: Yeah, just now the nougat stopped for a long time.
Jake: 跨跨服聊天
Jake: Cross-server chat.
Jake: 哈哈哈听到了一个
Jake: Haha, I heard one.
Lucia: 跨服聊天
Lucia: Cross-server chat.
Jake:哈哈哈听到了一段呵
Jake: Haha, I heard a bit.
Alice: 翻车翻车
Alice: It's a disaster, a disaster.
Alice: 这个颜色不太对
Alice: The color isn't right.
Alice: 应该是奶白色的
Alice: It should be milky white.
Alice: 不知道为什么
Alice: I don't know why.
Lucia: 没事我觉得应该会很好吃对你影响了什么
Lucia: It's okay, I think it'll taste good. How did it affect you?
Lucia: 哎绝了
Lucia: Oh, amazing.
Alice: 我很难受
Alice: I'm really upset.
Jake: 这个东西
Jake: This thing...
Jake: 保个温吧
Jake: Keep it warm.
Jake: 可以保温吗
Jake: Can it stay warm?
Lucia: 他应该是有一定保温功能的
Lucia: It should have some kind of insulation function.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我扔微波炉里面去
Jake: I'll throw it in the microwave.
Jake: 强势保温嗯
Jake: Strong insulation, hmm.
Lucia: 额你是放哪个微波炉里吗
Lucia: Uh, which microwave are you using?
Jake: 怎么有强势保温
Jake: How is it strong insulation?
Katrina:  咋了
Katrina: What's up?
Lucia: 没有就是我们的外卖到了
Lucia: Nothing, just our takeout arrived.
Jake: 哦强势保温
Jake: Oh, strong insulation.
Lucia:哈哈 所以经常就放在微波炉里保温了
Lucia: Haha, so we often just leave it in the microwave to keep warm.
Jake: 对那这个没有
Jake: Yeah, but this one doesn't.
Jake: 有个电饭锅
Jake: There's a rice cooker.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 物尽其用啊真
Lucia: Make the most of it, really.
Lucia: 能放下吗
Lucia: Can it fit?
Jake:进
Jake: Go in.
Jake: 放不下
Jake: It doesn't fit.
Jake: 但是问题不大
Jake: But it's not a big problem.
Jake: 楼上我们还有一个
Jake: We have another one upstairs.
Lucia: 哦有道理
Lucia: Oh, makes sense.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  昨天那个筷子
Katrina: Yesterday's chopsticks.
Jake:昨天的一次性筷子
Jake: Yesterday's disposable chopsticks.
Katrina:  因为没有勺子
Katrina: Because there were no spoons.
Katrina:  他做的
Katrina: He made it.
Jake: 有勺子，有肯德基留下的勺子
Jake: There's a spoon, a spoon left from KFC.
Katrina:  哦在这在这
Katrina: Oh, here it is, here it is.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Katrina:  我决定就是今天
Katrina: I've decided it's today.
Katrina:  呃修硕不是说那个货币嘛
Katrina: Uh, didn't Shure mention that currency?
Katrina:  嗯货币
Katrina: Yeah, currency.
Katrina:  我就打算能不能用那个
Katrina: I was thinking, can we use that?
Katrina:  我给你看那个贴纸他充当
Katrina: I'll show you that sticker, it acts like...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  因为贴纸他确实没法什么贴
Katrina: Because the sticker really can't be... you know, stuck on anything.
Katrina:  然后你买那货币的话
Katrina: And if you buy that currency,
Katrina:  越买游戏币也没啥用对吧
Katrina: Buying more game tokens isn't really useful, right?
Jake:哼哼哼哼哼
Jake: Ha ha ha ha ha.
Katrina:  那样的话
Katrina: In that case,
Jake:挺好
Katrina:  时时刻刻提醒他们
Katrina: It constantly reminds them,
Katrina:  参加过世界地球日的活动
Katrina: That they participated in Earth Day activities.
Lucia: 我觉得这个想法会更好
Lucia: I think this idea is even better.
Jake:挺好对
Jake: Sounds good, right.
Lucia: 因为贴纸大家还可以留着用油漆其他的没什么用
Lucia: Because everyone can keep the stickers and use them, paint, and other things aren't that useful.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: : 贴纸还便宜
Katrina: And stickers are cheap.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 换个位置吧
Lucia: Let's switch places.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 都是人才
Jake: Everyone here is talented.
Tasha:啊且慢
Tasha: Ah, hold on.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
Jake: 找什么呀
Jake: What are you looking for?
Lucia: 这个汤卷子的那个勺子用筷子怎么做呢但是勺子
Lucia: That soup dumpling spoon, how do you use chopsticks for that? But the spoon...
Jake: 勺
Jake: Spoon.
Lucia: 没有的话咱就只能用那个一次性的了
Lucia: If we don't have it, we can only use the disposable ones.
Jake: 勺对勺
Jake: Spoon, yes, spoon.
Jake: 中午肯德基
Jake: KFC for lunch.
Tasha: 什么时候吃饭
Tasha: When are we eating?
Alice: 失误了  我的错误
Alice: Oops, my mistake.
Jake: 已经饭已经到了
Jake: The food is already here.
Jake: 饭已经到了
Tasha: 在哪呢
Tasha: Where is it?
Jake: 随随时
Jake: Anytime.
Tasha: 吃呀
Tasha: Eat it.
Lucia: 在微波炉里
Lucia: In the microwave.
Tasha: 走吗
Tasha: Shall we go?
Jake:走走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 为啥不吃
Tasha: Why not eat?
Jake: 因为不是在等这个
Jake: Because we're not waiting for this.
Jake: 那个新做的饭吗
Jake: Is it the new meal?
Jake: 那个
Jake: That one.
Tasha: 哦 做好了都
Tasha: Oh, it's all done.
Jake:放汤
Jake: Serve the soup.
Jake: 好 那我不知道呀
Jake: Okay, I didn't know that.
Lucia: 那把这个拿下去放了
Lucia: Then take this down and serve it.
Jake: 现在知道了对
Jake: Now I know, right?
Lucia: 哎好激动啊
Lucia: Oh, so excited.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 灵魂像在那边在跳舞哈哈然后在斗舞
Jake: Feels like the soul is dancing over there, haha, like a dance battle.
Jake: 在斗舞就是
Jake: A dance battle, you know.
Tasha: 什么来着哼
Tasha: What was it again, hmm?
Tasha: 哎我还学过一段时间呢
Tasha: Oh, I learned it for a while.
Tasha: 学的啥呀
Tasha: What did I learn?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 这还要放胡椒粉
Katrina: Do we need to add pepper?
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Jake: 斗舞是吧
Jake: Dance battle, right?
Tasha: 好了大家都下来吃饭了
Tasha: Okay, everyone come down to eat.
Tasha: 不过为什么不在上面吃呢
Tasha: But why not eat upstairs?
Lucia: 因为土豆里下面好像比上面多一点
Lucia: Because there seem to be more potatoes downstairs than upstairs.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Lucia: 我想把这个拿上去
Lucia: I want to take this upstairs.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好你要不要把那个锅拿上去
Tasha: Alright, do you want to take the pot upstairs?
Tasha: 嗯把这碗汤汤端上去
Tasha: Hmm, take this bowl of soup upstairs.
Alice: 端上去
Alice: Take it upstairs.
Tasha: 对因为不是在上面吃饭吗
Tasha: Yeah, since we're eating upstairs, right?
Jake: 好我先端上去
Jake: Okay, I'll take it up first.
Jake: 额那就往那边放一放
Jake: Uh, just put it over there.
Lucia: 你叫哈哈
Lucia: You laugh, haha.
Jake: 对这样比较好
Jake: Yeah, it's better this way.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 是我的错觉还是这个
Lucia: Is it just me or is this...
Lucia: 这个房子那个没有下面那个料
Lucia: This house doesn't have the stuff below
Jake: 嗯这边有灯试一试
Jake: Hmm, there's a light here, try it out
Lucia: 好像好点了
Lucia: It seems better now
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 还可以还可以打灯
Jake: It's okay, we can still use the light
Lucia: 哎多拿点生菜
Lucia: Hey, grab more lettuce
Tasha: 端上去吧
Tasha: Take it up
Lucia: 上面桌子稍微空点
Lucia: The table up there is a bit empty
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow
Tasha: 我又受到熏陶了
Tasha: I'm influenced again
Jake: 怎么熏陶呢
Jake: How are you influenced?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 一起听吧你快
Jake: Listen together, hurry up
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How is it?
Tasha: 不应该说这些啊
Tasha: Shouldn't say this
Jake: 哈哈这是Siri吗猜PPT
Jake: Haha is this Siri guessing PPT
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this
Jake: 这是课吗
Jake: Is this a class?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 好了别听了
Tasha: Alright, stop listening
Tasha: 污染耳朵了
Tasha: It's polluting our ears
Tasha: 啊不应该说这些话啊
Tasha: Ah, shouldn't say this
Tasha: 不好意思
Tasha: Sorry
Jake: 大家不知道这是什么对
Jake: Nobody knows what this is, right?
Jake: 或
Jake: Or
Tasha: 有点黑暗的感觉
Tasha: Feels a bit dark
Alice:你知道他们为什么给你们这个呀
Alice: Do you know why they gave you this?
Tasha: 有点黑暗的感觉
Tasha: Feels a bit dark
Jake: 什么怎么黑暗了
Jake: What, how is it dark?
Tasha: 这个颜色不太对劲
Tasha: This color seems off
Alice:我害怕别看了
Alice: I'm scared, stop looking at it
Jake: 这叫胡辣汤
Jake: This is called Hu La Tang
Jake: 颜色为什么是里边什么皮蛋放多了
Jake: Why is the color like this? Too many century eggs?
Alice: 不知道
Alice: I don't know
Alice: 可能是水刚热的时候没有立即放进去
Alice: Maybe it wasn't added immediately when the water was hot
Jake: OK
Alice: 有干净的
Alice: Is there a clean one?
Alice: 碗呢？
Alice: A clean bowl?
Tasha: 我觉得要洗吧
Tasha: I think we need to wash it.
Tasha: 要不要给大家洗一些杯子
Tasha: Should we wash some cups for everyone?
Alice:额让我看看我这有
Alice: Um, let me see if I have some.
Lucia: 我就这样那一个好吧
Lucia: I'll just take this one, okay?
Tasha: 放到那里吧
Tasha: Just put it there.
Tasha: 放到桌上吧
Tasha: Put it on the table.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice: 占地吗？
Alice: Does it take up space?
Tasha: 不占地
Tasha: No, it doesn't.
Tasha: 这是汤
Tasha: This is soup.
Katrina:  这是汤吗
Katrina: Is this soup?
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Tasha: 我们有点汤吗
Tasha: Did we order some soup?
Lucia: 我们没点汤
Lucia: We didn't order soup.
Katrina:  这是番茄牛腩吗
Katrina: Is this tomato beef?
Tasha: 我靠这是番茄牛腩
Tasha: Oh my, this is tomato beef.
Lucia: 用汤看起来好像番茄汤啊
Lucia: It looks like tomato soup with the broth.
Tasha: 有备注不要香菜吗
Tasha: Did we note "no cilantro"?
Alice: 哎最后谁下单的啊
Alice: Hey, who placed the order?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 呃挑出来
Jake: Uh, pick it out.
Jake: 我给你都挑出来行不
Jake: I'll pick all of it out for you, okay?
Jake: 有戏有用吗
Jake: Will it work?
Alice:这是番茄牛腩
Alice: This is tomato beef.
Tasha: 这番茄牛腩太离谱了吧
Tasha: This tomato beef is too ridiculous.
Tasha: 你能不能联系一下商家
Tasha: Can you contact the seller?
Tasha: 你问问他
Tasha: Ask them.
Tasha: 这个真的是番茄牛腩
Tasha: Is this really tomato beef?
Jake:我看看
Jake: Let me see.
Alice: 额不是送了汤呵
Alice: Uh, didn't they give us soup?
Lucia: 这个看起来真的好像番茄汤
Lucia: This really looks like tomato soup.
Jake: 哪一个呀
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 番茄牛腩
Lucia: The tomato beef.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 这个不能用吧
Tasha: We can't use this, right?
Tasha: 嗯什么
Tasha: Hmm, what?
Alice:把这个开了
Alice: Turn this on.
Katrina: 哦这确实
Katrina: Oh, it really is.
Tasha: 都是直拍
Tasha: They are all vertical shots.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Tasha: 九宫格
Tasha: Nine-square grid.
Tasha: 一次性盒
Tasha: Disposable box.
Tasha: 这上面没有纸
Tasha: There’s no paper on this.
Lucia: 对这个上面好像我下拿那一包好吧
Lucia: Yeah, there seems to be none. I'll go get that pack, okay?
Alice:抱抱四个杯子拿过去可以吗
Alice: Can you take four cups over there?
Alice: 哎我这个是不是灭了
Alice: Hey, did mine go out?
Tasha: 哦你也灭了
Violet: Oh, yours went out too.
Alice:啊怎么了
Alice: Ah, what happened?
Lucia: 我也灭了
Lucia: Mine went out too.
Alice: 你也灭了哦
Alice: Yours went out too, huh.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 时间到了吧
Violet: Time's up, right?
Jake: 没关系对对对对
Jake: It's okay, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 灭了就灭了
Jake: If it goes out, it goes out.
Jake: 对灭了就摘了
Jake: Yeah, if it goes out, take it off.
Lucia: 对我这个在刚才就已经灭了
Lucia: Yeah, mine went out just now.
Lucia: 哈哈所以我已经摘下来了
Lucia: Haha, so I already took it off.
Jake: 没关系灭了就摘了
Jake: It's okay, if it goes out, take it off.
Jake: 那个没灭就带着
Jake: If it hasn't gone out, keep it on.
Lucia: 摘了
Lucia: Took it off.
Tasha: 全网唯一没灭的人
Violet: The only one in the whole network that didn't go out.
Jake: 谁
Jake: Who?
Jake: 你啊
Jake: You, huh.
Jake: 哦是吧
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 全网唯一你
Lucia: The only one in the whole network, you.
Lucia: 还真是
Lucia: It really is.
Lucia: 哦放没东西
Lucia: Oh, there's nothing in here.
Tasha: 为什么因为你采集到的数据太少了
Violet: Why? Because you collected too little data.
Jake: 哈哈因为我中间自己关了
Jake: Haha, because I turned it off myself in the middle.
Jake: 有我在上面
Jake: I’m on it.
小微;就是复古未见其实
Tasha: It’s just retro unseen, actually.
Tasha: 噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 在楼下吗
Violet: Are you downstairs?
Alice:对我在装东西
Alice: Yeah, I’m packing things.
Tasha: 拿个杯子上来行吗
Violet: Can you bring a cup up?
Tasha: 还少一个
Tasha: We're still missing one.
Alice:没问题
Alice: No problem.
Tasha: 呃要吧
Tasha: Uh, should we?
Tasha: 哦这有纸
Tasha: Oh, there's paper here.
Lucia: 嗯我以为我刚拿了两包上来
Lucia: Hmm, I thought I just brought up two packs.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 我刚刚还他问我要不要纸
Tasha: He just asked me if I needed paper.
Tasha: 我还说要
Tasha: And I said yes.
Lucia: 这个这个凳子是不是可以搬过来呢
Lucia: Can we move this chair over here?
Tasha: 我们的水机是不是用完了
Tasha: Is our water dispenser out of water?
Lucia: 没什么啦
Lucia: It's nothing.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 这个好像不太够煮辣西
Lucia: This doesn't seem enough to cook the spicy dish.
Jake: 够够的很
Jake: It's enough, definitely.
Lucia: 嗯但是这两个不是在用吗
Lucia: Hmm, but aren't these two in use?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个推过来放这
Lucia: Let's push this over here.